it's Prozac I can't believe you guys
right here that's like my teenage dreams
are coming true right now it
it's the faces behind Milo and Simon I'm
Simon this is Milo I'm not do most
people know you guys as Prozac when
you're walking down the street it was
never a secret yet you know we wanted to
emphasize the cartoon and of course the
cartoons are much better-looking
[Music]
they defined the nineties with their
multi-platinum albums and lovesick
ballads now 13 years later the iconic
cartoon duo is back with her first album
in over a decade
why now I blame the fans he believed
well we played a played a show at on the
quality Pop Festival I'm gonna have to
go and be such a bizarre amazing
experience we would sold out people
couldn't get in and we're dressed up as
Simon of Milo and you can do all the
words so I think that kind of inspired
us
[Music]
Love Me Tender is the lead single on
their new album so does that mean
Simon is still unlucky in love all these
years later do they actually find love
or are they still a little bit miserable
well Milo's always you know he is fun
yeah Simon is the perpetual you know sex
and love addict the pair hit the road
this week we're there forever 1999 tour
one that will tap into both old and new
music we go back to 99 what were you
guys doing what was one of the most
fondest memories because that's where
your success really happened
my favorite was opening for Destiny's
Child
[Music]
was that Canada's Wonderland when they
were doing shows there and before
Beyonce was this beautiful how do you
define success this time around if you
remember all the lyrics Me Tender make
it right rescue me tonight